what up reject nation you know the drill
we're gonna watch star wars visions
today this is episode six been enjoying
this show a lot five being our favorite
episode thus far guys hit that like
button if you end up enjoying our
reaction or the dislike it doesn't
matter which one just vote subscribe and
click that notification bell get
notified when our next reaction for
revisions is up as always full length
watch along so you sync up with the time
coder over at our patreon page cover a
whole bunch of shows over there where
you get options for reaction highlights
and watch alongs at the same tier lastly
thank you to prothop or jaden freddy in
this i don't know you guys alternate i
appreciate your hustle you two sexy boys
you
oh you boys never good
okay all done t-o-b-one t-o-b-one but
also two one i wonder if it was
intentional
did you make me bigger again next up is
co3 would you go get him please
[Music]
got a little bit of that ghibli vibe if
only they could make peace with disney
p1 how many times must i tell you you
must never go into the basement sorry
come along my children
let's get to work
we can stop only when there is life on
this planet and we are going to make
this a beautiful place that's an
ambitious goal yeah especially in this
universe the galaxy is terrifying and
full of danger
yes
it's only dangerous because the jedi are
needed what am i drawing well
this kid's gonna become mega man
oh yeah
his dad right here is professor light
it's perfect
you were imagining being a jedi again
don't ever do that again that's because
i want to become a jedi one day i am
afraid that being a jedi is not as
glamorous as it is in your dreams
that is a fact i keep having these
dreams and in them i'm a great jedi
force boy find yourself a kyber crystal
there is one somewhere on this planet so
if you really want to be a jedi you will
need to find a kyber crystal of your own
you are so supportive
especially given just how dangerous this
goal is yeah your overall goals you're
willing to put to the side just to help
him find his guy workers that is awesome
more supportive fathers in star wars
if i can't find the kyber crystal how am
i supposed to become a jedi
clear your mind
do you have a jedi background what's
going on here i bet he does
the force is present in all things
is it here is it
force are you there but i've already
searched everywhere on this planet
never go into the basement
attack on tied in
you've got a bad feeling about this
they said that every episode yeah i
think so
[Music]
let's take off wait a minute
i'm toby this is a call to all jedi if
you can hear me
[Music]
[Music]
yep
cool
jedi i had no idea
why didn't you tell me
in order to protect you so much for that
plan
wait was he an actual jedi or
i need you to stay hidden do not come
out for any reason
so is this the force please don't
deactivate me
co3 i'd leave this child to you i'm
going to die i'm one with the force
the force is with me
is he a kyber crystal i may
i'm sitting here going it's gotta be in
here somewhere
what happened to everyone oh no where's
the professor no
[Music]
oh
they bothered to give the others buried
him yeah it's nice
i'm gonna do it i'll continue the
research i'll fulfill the professor's
dream
[Music]
you're not gonna be looking for the
kyber crystal
he'll find it in pursuit of the
professor's dream
[Music]
help me tob1 you're our only hope
foliage the professor's theme has
finally come true
oh
[Music]
your revenge with the force
lightning shocked the tie fighter
jedi killer
it's his fault
so
there is another jedi on this planet
[Applause]
don't be afraid avatar the last
airbender
[Laughter]
do not worry you are prepared for this
fight toby
toby
you did well bringing life back to this
planet and you have proven that you have
grown up
ah
toby
ross
as a true jedi
ho ho cool force be with you oh my god
it's like a pinocchio and gepetto store
absolutely the force
lightning
oh
i'll bite your bleeding kneecaps off
[Applause]
oh dang
go droids no
oh my god he is like mega man
you only been a jedi for a day too
or like 10 minutes
it's a cozy
we will continue our research and the
professor's legacy of helping planets
because that's what jedi do
[Music]
cool that was lovely that was very very
enjoyable a great short film yeah that's
shitty chatty
one second
astro boy that's what uh that's what i
was my mind was sort of
jetted on over to i'm not that familiar
with astro boy but i think this is
riffing on it oh definitely i mean at
least the the look and the
general aesthetics and i mean i think
mega man is also a solid call just
because if you look at at least a lot of
the lore there you got you know like a
an old scientist just tinkering away
making these
human robo hybrids with massive ability
to combat other foes and whatnot and is
also uh definitely pinocchio gepetto
absolutely major story element there
um and then of course like
toby one
two b one two b one toby one how does he
pronounce it
t ob one and then he calls him toby
later yeah obi-wan and then this story
here does seem a little bit luke
parallels
the the planet that they inhabit his
home destroyed rises to become a jedi
yeah and these guys
[Music]
you know i mean even if he's not obi-wan
he's got the you know sage old white
beard yeah
it's it's cool how um
dark it got by the end of it with the
lightsaber fight because most of this
felt like the most like
other than like tattooing rhapsody that
this has so far felt like the most child
family friendly yeah thus far
um it just has that tone and i think
what really helps save a lot of the run
time is the is the execution of the tone
and because they switch up the animation
style it's easier to adjust because i
think sometimes with other shows you can
be sort of bogged down by run time but
when you got a specific story to tell it
seems that they just gave them the
amount of time they needed yeah to tell
the one story they wanted to tell it
does move pretty fast and i would have
liked it to be a tad longer but the same
time i kind of don't really mind that
it's the length that it is
because so much of the events move
really quick yeah but like i said
there's so much of what made it still
work and click for me is in its tone and
i love the idea too of maybe this isn't
like the star wars books that i'm not
familiar with but i love the idea of a.i
becoming a jedi like one being so in
tune with the force itself
that they're able to learn the ways of
the force and ways of the jedi and still
be called upon showing that a.i is
indeed life yeah you know so i love
having that quality inhabited here
um
so yeah i think what would have helped
with a little bit of extra run time is
really caring about the scientist jedi
character because when he died i was
like oh
yeah but it wasn't like yeah i didn't
feel the weight of the loss yeah just
moving so briskly by and also he does
like rise to jedi power so fast that
part of that pulls me out because i'm
like nah you would have got your ass
kicked yeah this guy's a
lord
you would have you would have been
totally wiped out
but
um
like i said if for like a if this played
as like some short film before some star
wars movie the way how pixar does that
with their movies and like this would
have been perfectly acceptable to me oh
absolutely i i really enjoyed yeah the
spirit and the whimsy and the charm of
this one i i do agree like a few extra
minutes to maybe not only with the
professor but also you know like when
he's bringing life back to the planet or
even that moment where he finds the
crystal within uh you know maybe just a
little bit more to kind of solidify and
let you experience
uh you know just the progress being made
because there is so much happening very
rapidly but uh yeah i really liked
just the the overall aura and spending
time on this planet getting to know
their little rapport with each other and
it's great in the way that they leave
you wanting more but not in a way that
hurts to me the episode it's like man i
would love to know who this professor is
and you know he said like this is what
he does he goes around and tries to save
planets and bring life back to these
places and you know he's also got his
whole array of little droids that he's
been working on and yeah as a you know
as a thematic idea of wow you know like
a droid could rise to this mantle and he
was clearly built by a jedi so maybe
there's something about that connection
specifically of like maybe he knew how
to imbue the force into his creation but
yeah i just thought it was a really
wonderful tale and yeah it had a kind of
pinocchio star wars sort of vibe and
there was like a coming-of-age quality
to it where it's like the you know toby
still maintains his innocence and his
you know good nature by the end but at
the same time you know there is a bit of
a growth into like yeah this guy's gonna
strike out onto the path of the jedi now
you know and carry on as his uh
ostensible father's work
yeah i just think that it could have
used a little bit more variety with our
the protagonist's
emotions because it is kind of one
the scientist gets a little bit more
layers but especially for this ai toby
who is developing life
he is just sort of like hippie the whole
time that's kind of how i would
associate his character one word
a little frustrated at times and then
comes right back around yeah yeah and i
think it would have just felt that much
more earned and i would have rooted that
much more for him in the end yeah but a
big part of what makes this so enjoyable
too like a lot of these i i have i am a
believer in that phrase of that when you
use the word but anything that comes
before it
doesn't really matter so i'll say
however because
or sometimes the word butt is applied
because ass it's the thing of like i do
feel that some of the criticisms that
i'm laying forth are totally valid it's
just that there's also the saving grace
of certain other elements like the
animation flourishes are just so damn
enjoyable oh yeah that it the the
emotion that that emits just makes it
makes it easier to forgive some of the
shortcomings
yeah it enhances the atmosphere and just
this aura of the setting a lot it's like
i love that pastel almost quality to a
lot of the animation where you feel kind
of the elements and the sounds
yeah yeah it really does and even like
and they do a great contrast because
when like plant life starts to show up
you're like oh wow
that does look like a breath of fresh
air in this wondrous desert world yeah
well yeah guys what did you think about
the episode leave your thoughts down
below uh i enjoyed it don't know where
i'd rank it yet we'll do a final ranking
by the time we get to episode nine but
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click that bell hit that like or dislike
button and uh yeah check us out on
patreon catch you guys soon
[Music]